in january 2010 inspectors with the un's
nuclear monitoring agency noticed
something strange at the nuclear
facility in atan's iran numerous
centrifuges at the crown jewel of iran's
nuclear program were failing centrifuges
are devices that produce enriched
uranium which can be used to make
nuclear weapons the cause of their
failure was a mystery it's believed the
us and israel ordered a cyber attack to
slow down iran's nuclear program a
computer worm called stuxnet reportedly
traveled on usb thumb drives and spread
through microsoft windows computers that
controlled the centrifuges sending
instructions for them to burn out
stuxnet didn't simply take over a
computer or steal information it
actually caused the equipment to
self-destruct it's more dangerous than a
computer virus while a virus is dormant
until the unwitting victim installs it a
worm can spread without being activated
sexnet is believed to have been created
by the us national security agency in
israeli intelligence though neither has
ever admitted responsibility their
collaborative effort was dubbed
operation olympic games it started under
the bush administration president obama
sped it up when he came into office in
2009 heeding bush's advice to continue
the cyber attacks president bush
believed it was the only way to prevent
israel from launching a conventional
strike on iranian nuclear facilities
like the one that targeted a syrian
nuclear reactor in 2007. israel has
never bought iran's argument that its
nuclear program is entirely peaceful for
the purposes of generating electricity
for example iran launched its nuclear
program in the 50s with the help of the
us through the atoms for peace program
in which america shared resources with
countries wanting to develop atomic
energy for peaceful activities in 1970
iran ratified the non-proliferation
treaty to limit its program for peaceful
use it meant iran would have to be
subject to inspection by the
international atomic energy agency those
inspectors with the iaea noticed
centrifuges mysteriously failing at the
start of 2010. getting the worm into the
nitons facility was actually the final
step of a carefully planned attack
this is what is believed to have
happened the nsa and the israeli
military wrote a program that digitally
mapped out the workings of iran's natanz
plant the program is introduced into a
controller computer at the plant
possibly by an oblivious plant worker
the program collects information on how
the computers and the facility are
configured the agencies use the data to
design a complex worm stuxnet stuxnet is
introduced into the plant's computer
controllers via a usb stick stuxnet was
designed to target computers with a
specific siemens software program this
program was used by industrial computers
to control and monitor the centrifuges
the worm takes over control of the
centrifuges causing them to spin too
fast or too slow they become unbalanced
and in some cases explode centrifuges
spin at supersonic speeds to separate
isotopes in uranium gas uranium enriched
and 90 or more can be used to make
nuclear weapons according to the new
york times the centrifuges first began
to crash in 2008. initially the attacks
were small and seemed like random
accidents as variations in the code
prompted different types of breakdowns
which confused the iranian engineers by
the spring of 2010 the nsa in israel's
secretive intelligence unit 8200
prepared to ramp up their attack to
target a thousand centrifuges but the
worm was discovered that summer a
programming air sent the worm onto the
laptop of an iranian engineer the laptop
had reportedly been hooked up to the
systems controlling the centrifuges the
stuxnet worm was replicated across the
internet spreading wildly and attacking
computers in india indonesia and china
it's eventually tracked down and
disassembled by security researchers
president obama decided to continue the
operation anyway and stuxnet took out
nearly a thousand centrifuges or about a
fifth of those operating
there's been debate about how the worm
actually got into the nuclear facility
according to one theory israel hired an
iranian double agent or agents to infect
the facility with a corrupt memory stick
another theory according to security
software firm semantic is that the
attackers infected computers at five
outside companies connected to the
nuclear program and somehow managed to
find its way to natanz experts who
analyze the computer worm say it was far
more complex and brilliant than anything
they had ever seen the attackers even
secretly recorded what a normal day at
the plant looked like and then played
those readings back to plant operators
so they didn't think anything was wrong
as the centrifuges were tearing
themselves apart kind of like a
pre-recorded security tape during a bank
heist in movies like ocean's 11. the u.s
believes the attack set back iran's
nuclear program by up to two years
others believe this is an overestimation
iran denied that it's well-known
struggles to enrich uranium were caused
by stuxnet the country had always
insisted its nuclear program was for
peaceful purposes that is until a former
head of iran's nuclear agency let slip
in 2021 that iran's growth involved
quote satellites missiles and nuclear
weapons faradun abbastavani spoke to
state media on the anniversary of the
assassination of iranian nuclear
scientist muzin fakhrizadeh by the
israeli government currently the biden
administration is trying to revive a
2015 agreement that curbs iran's nuclear
work in return for relief from sanctions
it would see iranian oil come back on
the market at a time when the u.s has
banned russian oil president trump had
exited the nuclear deal critics worry
that iran could develop nukes under the
guise of working toward peaceful ends
the stuxnet computer worm has vast
repercussions today computer security
experts have described stuxnet as an
instruction manual of sorts sean mcgurk
a former cyber security official at the
u.s department of homeland security
noted that the stuxnet source code could
be downloaded modified and directed at
new targets during an interview with 60
minutes he said this in reference to
those who created the sophisticated
cyber weapon they opened the box they
demonstrated the capability it's not
something that can be put back
in 2012 iranian hackers are believed to
have unleashed a virus against the saudi
arabian petroleum and natural gas
company saudi aramco they stole
passwords destroyed data and prevented
rebooting on tens of thousands of
computers a document leaked by edward
snowden and provided to the intercept
showed the nsa believed iran had
demonstrated a clear ability to learn
from the capabilities and actions of
others strengthening the fears of the us
intelligence community that iran had
learned from american cyber attacks it
takes a small team to make videos here
at news think it's really important for
me to not stress out so i can feel good
and be as productive as possible i have
trouble sleeping myself and for the past
few months i've been taking magnesium
breakthrough and i've noticed my sleep
has gotten a lot better besides getting
better sleep my sponsor by optimizers
aims to help you beat stress and fatigue
most magnesium supplements fail because
they're synthetic or use preservatives
whereas magnesium breakthrough contains
all seven critical forms of magnesium
that are truly needed to regulate the
body to try the powerful effects of
magnesium for yourself head to magnesium
breakthrough dot com slash newsthink to
get a 10 discount be sure to use the
promo code newsthink10 at checkout you
can click my custom link in the
description or pin comment thanks for
watching for newsthink i'm cindy palm
[Music]